this is a production of Cornell
University
excellent thanks for the introduction
Jenny
yeah I'm going to spend some time with
you talking about more of a case study
approach I think in New York in terms of
handling nitrogen Dynamics documenting
and managing field nitrogen use for
greenhouse gas reduction is the title
since Jenny told me that the audience
today is quite diverse I put up this
agenda and first start out with talking
a little bit about what we do in our
program here at the nature management
spear program or nmsp
and set the stage real briefly about
agriculture in New York in a regulatory
environment we work in
and then talk about on-farm research and
Tool development in our program and then
dive into for the core of the
presentation in two approaches whole
Farmhouse balances as a tool for
evaluation and field-based adaptive
management for nitrogen
let's dive in right away my job
a little over 20 years ago when I joined
Cornell
my job description said that I was to
provide leadership for the nature
management extension program for the
College of Ag and Life Sciences at
Cornell University
and that that program should improve
growers in agriculture industry
awareness of the crop nutrient needs
crop quality management of organic
wastes environmentally sound inter
management practices in general and then
overall soil fertility management
that job description is as relevant now
as it was 20 years ago the only thing I
would change is the word waste we are
talking about resources and not waste
when there is a tremendous resource and
has all the essential nutrients so our
goal is here to try to figure out how we
manage that the best to benefit our crop
production our soil Health our soil
resilience
and reduce the impact on the environment
we have a website and nutrient
management should be a program website
nmsp.calls.cornell.edu if you're
interested in looking at
aspects that I'm talking about today in
more detail before I go on I'm the
speaker for the session here today but
for the last 20 years I've worked
closely together with Carl zimik
colleague from Pro Dairy who
transitioned to working for dairy
Management Inc now and is no longer with
Pro Dairy
um we were very fortunate to hire uh
Kirsten Workman as a replacement for
Carl zimmick within the pro Dairy
program and she and I are working
together moving this forward now just
want to recognize their contributions
all right so the ultimate goal of our
program is to have impact to
facilitate a change for the better
we want to develop and Implement better
management practices at the farm level
the field level within field levels
state level as well
contributes to Agriculture and
Environmental Management policy in the
state of New York strong believer that
we need to talk to each other to develop
the best possible approaches
we want to engage farmers in on the farm
research based on the recognition that
if you can see for yourself that
something does or doesn't make a
difference
you're gonna adapt much more quickly
seeing as believing
and then the last item here I'll come
back with one slide totally at the end
of this presentation but we find it
really important that our undergrad and
grad population is involved in thinking
about solutions to environmental
challenges environmental agricultural
challenges and that we engage them in
multidisciplinary projects including
research extension and teaching
so for those of you not familiar with
New York
we are a predominant theory states uh
New York is the fourth highest milk
producer in the U.S
and the dairy industry is really
important to the economy of New York as
well
we grow a lot of crops to support animal
Agriculture and one of those main crops
is corn corn for silage there's also
corn for grain we have over a million
acres of corn grown on an annual basis
we also have a lot of water resources in
the state of New York and we would like
to keep that clean
we have an environmental footprint that
we would like to reduce as much as we
can
and we want to conserve carbon so there
are multiple environmental aspects here
it could make the lists much larger
recognizing we need biodiversity and
many other aspects of Agriculture as
well but here are the key ones that we
work on in in our program
so to address the environment of
footprints that includes nutrients that
includes greenhouse gas emissions it
includes looking at Carbon cycling
I think we require a focus on Precision
management at all systems that was
brought up with one of the last
questions asked and after armin's
presentation
we want to focus on all system levels
the coast the fields the storage the
manure storage the feed storage the
bunks
I want to use technology as it becomes
available as it is developed to increase
production per resource use output per
unit of lens output per unit of
investment
want to match the crop needs with inputs
given establish feasible balances
feasible benchmarks feasible
targets for any of the tools we develop
because it helps us measure how we are
doing and it helps us document how we
move forward
you want to engage everybody wants to
engage with us in on-farm research given
the power of doing
test trials at your own Farm
and then the main thing is here we need
tools
to become comfortable with management
decisions with management changes over
time so you need to develop tools to
measure and monitor progress over time
I'm going to take you back real briefly
to New York regulatory environments
back in 99 this regulator in the state
of New York the New York State
Department of Environmental Conservation
released the first kfo permit kfo stands
for concentrated animal feeding
operations
this permit
relied heavily
um natural resources conservation
service standards
these are guidelines on particular
aspects of farming and the one that's
most appropriate for us to work with and
think about is the 590 Nutri management
standard
and his five nine inter measurements
then it refers directly to the land
brand University guidelines
in a free translation that sort of says
that in terms of fertility management
how much nitrogen how much phosphorus
how do I
distribute a dome of the land base
these standards and this k for permit is
referring back to develop guidelines at
the land grant University which is
Cornell University for New York
if you look at the 590 standards and you
do a quick search for the word Cornell
you will find it's referenced 93 times
in this document just to show the link
between
um the regulatory environment and the
science
supported science
um
driven recommendations as we developed
them here at Atlanta and University
right our website has access for folks
that are interested in knowing what
those guidelines are
there's one particular page that is
specifically for nurture management kfo
planning CNP planning all right
we have on the website both the fact
sheets and then that website for the
Cornell University guidelines for
comprehensive nature management plans
where people can find out what the
relevant documents are in terms of of
guidance for inter management planning
all right
so
we don't work in a vacuum
I mentioned uh we team up with our
colleagues consumek in the past and now
Kristen Workman
um on all of these issues we work with a
lot of Partners throughout the state in
New York and we have officially
recognized advisory committees an
internal advisory committee with Cornell
Cooperative Extension indicators as well
as Cornell faculty and staff and an
external committee that has our
Regulatory Agencies our state agencies
The Soil and Water Conservation
districts represented
the Northeast Dairy Producers
Association the Farm Bureau farmers are
on this committee consulting firms are
participating other Sunni institutes are
participating this is a committee that
is knowledgeable about agriculture and
can give us feedback on what is
practical what is what is doable what
needs to be addressed where are the
barriers what are the opportunities for
moving forward
so just to outline what our
our mission is in our program and how we
try to work together with our partners
to actually
um execute that mission
all right so on-farm research and Tool
development is really important if you
want to move forward with improved
management
we try to build Partnerships with an
on-farm presence the map on the left is
one of our first projects that we
started where we looked at how much
phosphorus we needed and every dot is a
farm that participated with a non-farm
trial those type of networks are
important to build
so that we can draw conclusions not just
for an individual field but across many
farms for the state of New York
on the right of the screen you see a
snapshot of our website there is the
on-farm research partnership websites
that has listed right now 12 active
programs active projects
and each of those has some more
information if you're interested in
diving into that
what type of things do we do well manure
was already mentioned it's a big a big
source of nutrients it could also be a
problem if it's uh
if those nutrients aren't reaching the
crops but are being lost in the
environment so we work with producers
Consultants custom operators
um evaluation of equipment to apply
manure as one way to reduce emissions
and to increase nitrogen use efficiency
when your injection studies one example
of that
we just got funded for a manure
fertilizer replacement program
um New York Farm viability and Northern
New York AG development program funded
uh trials that we're going to conduct
with Farmers throughout the state where
we look at the true value of manure in
terms of nitrogen replacement value so
if we spread manure do we still need
fertilizer and this is a nice example of
showing that that is not
that's always the case manure has value
and the other thing that we want to
identify here is what is the yield
benefits of manure so these type of
studies are very common for us to to
look at
we are working on crop rotations keeping
the ground covered trying to assess the
benefits of cover crops for for nutrient
uptake in the fall and credits in the
spring
expanding that to letting that cover
crop over winter and grow for a couple
of weeks so that we can Harvest it as a
first cutting so crop rotations but
we're looking at different crops what
are the options to keep the ground
covered and increase productivity
we develop tangible tools where we
calibrate them if they're developed
elsewhere
examples here on the screen are the corn
stock nitrate tests the Illinois or
nitrogen test
introduced a new buffer pH approach
um in our our lab facilities and a new
silver test as well tangible things soil
analysis plant analysis type stuff
but we're also looking at digital tools
and the focus here is accessibility
here's an example of a publication we we
just put out last year trying to see if
we can use cameras on our cell phones
to get a better sense of how much carbon
and nitrogen is in the cover crop in the
fall before winter in the spring before
we terminate the stand
technology used in terms of yield data
is really important for us as well
measuring yields is really important to
making changes in management if you keep
guessing it's difficult to be
comfortable
so we've worked with with farmers who
have field monetary equipment or work
with custom operators that have that to
look at their raw data
apply a cleaning protocol so we take out
the errors in these maps and then turn
it into yield stability zones that tell
people that okay in the green areas I'm
consistently High yielding
in the red areas I'm consistently low
yielding and green and and sorry blue
and yellow are variable over years one
year high one year low very much subject
to the weather
we're now at the most advanced stages of
uh of looking at yield monitors working
with satellite and drone imagery let's
see can we can we make this type of
yield assessment accessible for more
people
particularly the satellite imagery has
promised for that
the last one is a quick update in terms
of tools we developed guidance documents
guidance on groundwater protection
guidance on nitrogen leaching index
assessments
one of the more recent ones that we
developed was the phosphorus index and
I'm just showing this to show you the
collaboration that goes into developing
the guidance
this was working with all our partners
in the State farmers Farm advisors
agency folks large databases 30 000
fields that we were able to tap into
30 Farmers with whole Farm information
to plan our surveys get feedback from
the planning Community evaluation of
impact all of these together resulted in
the release of a new tool that is now
being implemented here on farms in New
York
just a slight we're not going to talk
about phosphorus but just to slide to
show the Partnerships that are required
for building these type of guidelines
all right let's dive into two tools the
first one is the whole Farmhouse balance
tool
before I actually explain what that
means I wanted to share this slide this
is from Jim cambrado colleague out of
Purdue a statement that was made in
their nitrogen management update last
year
and in here it says remember that
nitrogen used in corn is part of a
complex biological system that interacts
with everything under the sun and it's
difficult to model with computer
programs
we cannot accurately predict the weather
we cannot accurately predict soil and
Supply or availability throughout the
year yet we cannot afford financially or
environmentally to Simply apply more
than enough
and this to me summarizes our current
understanding of nitrogen cycling the
diversity our month's presentation was a
a really great example of how complex
all these these things are and how
difficult it is to have a single
solution for all of this
it also points out the importance of
developing tools that help us evaluate
how well we are doing
and Lauren over time
so to neutralize balance one of those
tools this is a tool at the whole Farm
level
in this particular approach so systems
sort of a systems accounting approach we
look at the farm and we draw a boundary
around it and we say what is coming onto
this Farm in terms of nutrients feed
fertilizer to primary two ones on our
our dairy farms there might be some
animals coming onto the farm and some
Farms are importing bedding material
extra
we also have nutrients that leave the
farm in terms of exports milk is the
prime export for dairy farms but they're
also Farms that export crops Some Farms
export manure and there might be some
animals leaving the farm
you take the difference between imports
and exports you get the balance
and this is on the nutrients pool of
nutrient basis
we can divide that balance in terms of
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium that
we're using now
per total amount of land that the farm
is cropping it's a portable acre
cropland
we can also divide it by the total
amount of milk that the farm produces
and those are the two key indicators per
syllable acre
is a reflection of do we have the land
base to recycle the nutrients
the 100 weights is more of a production
efficiency number and both are important
we had the opportunity to work with a
lot of firms over the last many years
and back in 2006 we had a database of
about 102 Farms
that we were able to analyze and say
okay what what's reality for these Farms
what are we doing what are the
opportunities
based on that evaluation
we set
feasible limits feasible balances
and for nitrogen that feasible balance
was between 0 and 105 pounds per acre
if it's less than zero it means we're
mining our resources not a good thing
if it's greater than 105 it's signaled
in this database that the firms might
have had opportunities to improve their
balances
and knowing that the biggest drivers are
feeding fertilizer
improving balances meant addressing
the feeding program and addressing the
fertilizer program
opportunities to reduce balances driven
primarily by feed and fertilizer
decisions that are being made at the
farm level
so this particular assessment by working
with the Farms by the farm sharing their
data with us
we were able to evaluate a Statewide
database and give some guidance as to
you know where where should we strive to
be
for nitrogen our range right now is
between zero and 105 pounds of nitrogen
per acre
exceeding that is a signal that it might
be possible to reduce those balances
save some money
and reduce the environmental footprint
the greenhouse gas emissions because
anytime you over fertilize you increase
the amount of loss to the environment
so those numbers in a table look nice
but it's much more visible if we have a
figure for this and we have here is a
example of a whole bunch of farms with
their balances here's the milk per acre
and here is The Milk Bar sorry here's
the milk break and here's the balance
breaker the nitrogen balance break
I set one zero to 105 that's this this
box this blue box
every Farm that's in here in the blue
box is meeting the feasible balances per
acre
now we also want to look at production
efficiency that's equally important and
production efficiency is in this
diagonal so the yellow triangle reflects
the Farms that are more most efficient
in terms of balances per 100 weight they
have the lower balances per hundred
weight
if you overlay blue and yellow you get
the green box
and that Green books box is where Farms
meet both the feasible balances for
balance per acre and a balance per 100
weight in this case in the example of
nitrogen
hopefully that makes sense
um this allowed us to visualize our farm
results and to start looking at if the
farm comes back and you're here
somewhere
250 pounds per acre for the same amount
of milk that farm might have
opportunities to improve
Farms that participate in this
assessment now are getting a report they
fill in the input sheets it's four pages
it's ask basic information about how
much fertilizer is imported how much
feed was imported with the milk export
and things like that
and they get the farm back with boxes
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium is
what we're reporting on right now for
this talk nitrogen was the focus so
let's take a look here
this is the nitrogen balanced pounds per
acre again and the milk production and a
farm gets their dots
in this figure somewhere in the example
here it's in the green box
they get it for three nutrients
in addition if they participate for a
longer term they get their Trends in the
same report
so these are the trends for the balance
per acre for nitrogen for phosphorus and
potassium again and some Farms you can
really well a lot of farms actually you
can really see the improvements over
time when you do this for multiple years
we will always see fluctuation in these
balances and that's driven by the
weather if it is a drought here we have
less yields we have to import that
drives up the balances
so you'll see later that we calculate
with three year running averages for
this
same thing for the balance per 100
weights this is uh
the balance 100 weight again for
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium
also important to look at those those
Trends over time
in addition to the balance figures the
greenbox figures and their Trend figures
the Farms get a opportunity table
this is what we currently have in the
opportunity table it lists the farm
balances in lines one and two
and Compares it to benchmarks that came
out of our research database
so here's the 105. if the farm exceeds
the 105 which it does in this example it
gets flagged so everything that's
flagged in here is exceeding what we
established as feasible balances and
this is not a hard cut off this is
basically saying that for example if
your animal density exceeds 1.0 it's
more difficult to be in the green box
it's more difficult to meet the balances
if you don't export manure
so this is a an example Farm was high on
nitrogen
um one of the things that jumps out is
the purchase feed
is exceeding the feasible balances this
could trigger attention by the farm to
say okay what are we exactly feeding do
we need all of it where are the losses
all right feed and fertilizer as I
mentioned are typically the biggest
drivers for balances
so the opportunities are also in
addressing feed and fertilizer decisions
yeah
now if you do this type of analysis with
a lot of farms you can start pulling
their information together and this is
again the beauty of farm sharing their
information with us
we can do Trend analysis at Watershed or
state levels and we did that for the
upper South Carolina Watershed part of
the Chesapeake Bay
and for the need for New York State and
what this is really showing very
illustratively is that if we start
measuring things we start making better
decisions we had reductions in total nnp
Imports comparing 2004 to 2013 when we
did this assessment
of 66 million pounds of nitrogen in the
state of New York not applied in 2013
compared to 2004.
6.6 million pounds of phosphorus not
applied in 2004 not imported onto the
Farms
not used at all
not brought in so if you don't bring it
in you can't lose it
these are tremendous reductions 25 30
depending on what what watershed or
state level we look at about 20 for
phosphorus enormous reductions
simply not importing it anymore if we
don't need it and we did not give up on
the milk production we did a crop
production actually slowly increased
all right that was an example of an
evaluation to let the whole Farm level
Farms to participate do this around this
time of the year they fill in the forms
they send it to us we either give them
their report back
um
it doesn't specifically tell you what to
do in terms of decision making it just
points out some direction of opportunity
is it the feeding side or is it the
uh the fertilizer side of things
right so there's plenty of room for
follow-up questions once people get
their reports back
we are working with a more recent data
set of three years we have about the 50
farms in the database
where we have a consistent three-year
timeline for all of them
and we are evaluating bets for
additional indicators that we could add
to this
opportunity table
looking for more key performance
indicators that can help firms identify
where the opportunities are and monitor
change over time
all right I want to spend a little bit
more time now on on the core of of
nitrogen management at the field base
as was already pointed out nitrogen is
is difficult to manage it has the
potential to escape on us in one formal
way whether it's nitrates or n2o or NH3
um
but as Jim cavarado said we cannot just
afford to apply enough just enough to
make sure we just have enough and
instead of that we need to be more
comfortable with making decisions about
when do I need it and when do I don't
need it how much do I need if I do need
extra nitrogen
everyone also stayed up front at a
malnourished plant is a leaky plant we
under fertilizing is
it is not the way to go
if we impact plant Health we implect the
plant's performance everything else you
can imagine in terms of the whole
Farmhouse balances if I can't grow
homegrown forages and I have to import
those that has a much larger
environmental footprint both for
nutrients and greenhouse gas emissions
all right so we're going to focus on
adaptive management policy but before I
dive into this I want to bring up this
equation this is equation that is the
foundation of recommendations coming out
of Cornell University land print system
we basically say that a good Target to
shoot for in terms of nitrogen
requirements for corn is a function of
what we expect the yield to be yield
potential
what we expect the soil to supply
through soil organic matter
mineralization the soil and component
here
what we expect to get from crop
rotations and it's listed here salt but
it could could be cover crops it could
be a previous year hay fields or it
could be soybean credits
and then we recognize that there is such
a thing as fertilizer uptake efficiency
not all of the fertilizer we apply can
be taken up
and we take that into account
we also have a dairy industry in the
states manure again is a tremendous
nutrient source so we take that into
account with our recommendation system
as well crediting both current and past
years manure applications
so that we lower the amount of nitrogen
we recommend if there is manure in the
system
foreign
so back in 2000s when the first kfo
permit came out and regulations came in
place
farmers in New York that fall under
these recommendations uh at least these
regulations had two options
they could use a corneal potential that
was in our yield database at Cornell and
it's a database I inherited when I
started working at Cornell
and the equation that I just showed you
so I would look up soil type look up
what the yield potential for that soil
type was listed as plugged it into
equation and then derived the
recommendation
the second option that was put in place
by state partnership was that they could
use their own yield data
if a farm had three years of yield data
they could substitute the book values
for their own yielding
and this reflects that book values are
always off one way or another
the if you have your own data it was
highly incentivized to use your own data
to derive recommendations
thanks to a partnership of farmers and
crop consultants in the state and custom
Harvesters in the states we over the
past five years have been able to pull
together an enormous database of proper
data for corn
so a quick update is that we now have a
new yield database
we were able to analyze uh about 230 000
acres of corn yield data
that does not include 2001 this is the
summary up until we're still working on
2001.
and from this database we're able to
generate a new database for corn grain
and initiates a database for corn silage
as well that database is currently under
review testing
but open up the door for us to do
something new and in my view really
constructive in terms of rules and
regulations in our land Grand Mission
was the introduction of the concept of
adaptive Management in the state in in
the nrcs federal policy
at the federal level nrcs in 2011
natural resource conservation service
released Agronomy Tech note number six
on adaptive nature management
it was an update in 2013 of that same
document
and what this basically opened the door
for was on Farm testing as a way to make
improvements over time rather than fixed
values
and the the circle here on the right of
the screen is sort of you you take stock
of what you have step one
you plan for some management change to
be evaluated you implement
that evaluation step four you look at
the results of you that you got step
five you act on those results and make
changes so it's it's the process of
continuous Improvement through
measurements through experimentation in
one sense or another
the original document of nrcs stated
that the experimentation
could include nitrogen rate studies to
determine the optimal end rates and had
to be replicated at least four times
in New York we got together with the
agencies
and talked about how we could Implement
something adaptive management related in
New York and we released two fact sheets
fact sheets 77 and 78 back in 2013.
that adaptive management process was
updated with the input of our external
advisory committees in 2018. and Farms
that are regulated now have four options
basically
you can use the book values
you can use your own yield data and a
lot of farms are beginning to collect
those
or you can take the Adaptive management
approach that could include replicated
nitrogen rate trials but it could also
include the evaluation of a management
change
uh in a different way
and it's the last bullet point that I
think is most important here Farms can
now take the Adaptive management
approach and evaluate if a change in
management
makes a difference
but as soon as they do that they have to
start measuring yields and do an
environmental assessment to see if
that's higher nitrogen rate was really
needed
the tool that was introduced at that
time is an Adaptive management tool so
if you want to do adaptive management
you need evaluation tools
the first tool that was introduced was
this corn stock nitrate test
where you take a piece of the sample at
Harvest Time you analyze it for nitrate
and then you look at the numbers and say
that the policy says that if the results
exceed 3000 PPM
for two years nitrogen rates need to be
reduced with continued yields and season
D monitoring until the season teas are
routinely below three thousand
this is an Adaptive management approach
you keep measuring
and dialing in until it's in the the
until it's below the 3000. the concept
here is that at some stage the yield
levels off when you put fertilizer out
on manure whatever it is that supplies
the nitrogen
from that moment on the yield does not
increase anymore but the stock levels do
increase and therefore this is a really
useful test in terms of adaptive
management end of season evaluation tool
since 2018 there are some other options
so the C's and T is still in the list of
options Farms can use that we recommend
to sample the top yielding area of a
field
um there are also a couple of other
options including putting in a jack
strip with the control treatment and
then we have a forward option here that
I want to spend a few minutes about this
as well the fourth option is to do a
field balance
the field balance itself is basically
supplied mine is taken up
there was an additional thing that was
brought into the Adaptive management
policy in 2018 and that was saying if
your farm with a three-year running
average is at or below 105 pounds per
acre
break a balance
you meet the Adaptive management
guidelines and do not have to do any
field specific evaluations Beyond
recording yield
so this is a tool the mass balance now
being incentivized through adaptive
management policy in the state of New
York
all right so that field balance coming
back to that we excluded corn at that
time uh 2018 because we didn't quite
know how to do it but we have a better
sense now so we're working on that
what is a balance in terms of a field
balance it's simply an inputs or Supply
minus the output so fertilizer manure
rotation credit soil and we compared it
to how much the crop actually took up
and removed
here's an example of one Farm
every bar you see on the chart here is a
field on that farm
and there are two lines on this
black line on the chart now let's take a
look at the left the black line on the
left here
is the total amount of nitrogen taken up
by the crop in that particular field in
that particular year
so this is uptake
yields times percent nitrogen
the blue line is the nitrogen supplied
to this each of these particular fields
and we rank them from left to right
based on the difference between those
two numbers
on the left Supply and uptake are very
close together in this example
on the right they are very far apart
and if you want to take a look at the
last four Fields here all of them are
somewhere between I don't know around
250 pounds of nitrogen Supply
less than 100 pounds taken up
if you see this and these are your
Fields your immediate attention will go
to these fields and say okay I obviously
did not need the fertilizer here
yellow is the fertilizer
how can I improve on these fields over
time and these would signal for the most
part that this line here the black line
with the yields
illustrates that nitrogen was not an
issue a crop limiting issue in these
fields
we supplied more than twice the amount
taken up here and the crop yields was
lower
than the fields on the left here
you can do these balances for available
nitrogen that discount that manure is
not 100 efficient
we can do it for total nitrogen where
every pound of nitrogen and manure is
added to the calculation reality is
probably somewhere in the middle
we've done this for Four Farms now two
years of data so these are all the same
type of figures
what I want to point out here is some
opportunities so we have for example
this Farm B here
um there are some Fields here
where the balance is negative
that's not sustainable over the long
term
here's some some questions there to be
looked at them maybe we we might have an
opportunity for increased yields here
maybe
on the right here we'll see a whole
bunch of fields where again the yield is
among the lowest on the farm it's really
not nitrogen limited so we have
opportunities to save on our fertilizer
expenses
so what we hope in terms of adaptive
management
that Farms are participating with the
whole Farm has balance and identify if
they have opportunities for saving at
the whole Farm level but also dive into
more specific field based management
by evaluating at the end of the season
these are all end of season tools
we cannot change what was done in the
season with these tools but we can
evaluate how well we did and let that
inform our decision making moving
forward
Farms that have yield monitors can do
this type of balances also at the within
field level
and identify where areas are that they
could do variable rate application
within the field level
all right want to leave some time for
questions here so I'm going to focus a
little bit on a summary and then one
more slide
um
another topic
so our program neutral management should
be a program at the College of Ag and
Life Sciences at Cornell University is
tasked with the land grant mission in
inter management for field crops in New
York
we don't work in a vacuum we have
advisory committees we work with and we
work in partnership with all the state
agencies
we develop guidelines that we want to be
a science supported as can be
recognizing that especially for nitrogen
management is a challenge and that we
can strive to be better
um
with what we do but there's always going
to be uncertainty
going back to the statement that my
colleague out of Purdue made
so the guidelines are posted on this
website our focus with the program is on
development of practical tools for crop
nutrient management
and tools that allow for troubleshooting
and evaluation
we basically look for tools that can
tell us are we on the right track are we
going in the right direction and can we
show at the same time the progress
already made at the at the state level
nitrogen is difficult to manage
everybody will recognize that
I don't want to point out and it's often
forgotten that both under application so
not enough and over application can
result in problems
so finding ways to fine-tune to better
meet the needs of the crops
over space different fields and over
time different seasons different weather
patterns is important
the Adaptive management approach that we
introduced in the state of New York
is in my viewer absolutely key in moving
us forward
if we
incentivize on a farm experimentation
we have a much more rapid impact
and it's much easier for a producer to
see that something
can be changed
we gotta we gotta be able to manage the
risk and we got to know where the risk
is
so adaptive management is key
within that you need evaluation steps
and this concept of freedom to explore
in the Adaptive management system so
farmers can override the land grant
guidance and apply beyond what was
recommended with the freedom to explore
and the responsibility to evaluate If
there really was an improvement
foreign
Mission and our Cornell motto
sharing of data allow us to document
progress and to develop new tools as
well and we saw that when we developed
the mass balance the whole Farm has
balance feasible balances where you
could base that on farmer Farmer input
um
it is really really useful for those
databases to be pulled together and to
learn from them so we can figure out
what is deriving these balances and
where we can make changes
Partnerships and incentive programs are
really essential as well here in New
York we have an overall a really good
partnership among the agencies
a good partnership with the planning
community and the farmers in the state
and we might not always agree but we
discuss and we are able to explore
different opportunities
in our shared documents are our result
of that partnership
well Farmhouse balances are an
evaluation tool at the whole Farm level
it will help us
[Music]
identify if there's overall
opportunities for improvement and give
us some guidance whether we should look
at the cropping system or the feeding
system or
storage aspects of the farm
the Adaptive management process that I
talked about today in terms of field
balances in terms of Cs and T's that is
field-based forward and field based
an additional approach to becoming more
comfortable with our manure and
fertilizer decisions over time
if any of you on the on the call or in
New York uh interested in
evaluating
at the farm level contact us we're happy
to work with anybody to uh evaluate
nutrient use at the farm level and
listed here both the website and my my
email
as well as the screenshot of the on Farm
research partnership again
this is the last slide not to forget
that
the future will need bright Minds to
work forward with because this is not
going to get less complex
we have to come up with with Solutions
we have to engage the Next Generation in
finding solutions to act and
Environmental Management coming up with
better tools so I just want to show this
we are on Twitter now
and these are stories that were put out
over the last
six months or so of students at Cornell
all
associated with whole Farm Theory
sustainability aspects Precision act
aspects and we have also launched our
PhD student I've seen Oliva on the
program has developed a curriculum for
whole Farmhouse balances that is now
being implemented at High School classes
as well
thanks to everybody that participated in
all of what I share today as I mentioned
when I started out I'm presenting it but
it's actually refracting partnership
with a lot of folks
um
in the state of New York and
other states as well as we form National
networks with many of our programs as
well
with that back to you Jenny
thank you so much curing that was
fantastic as you know I love your
adaptive management
um Dan if you can put the poll out that
would be great and I will start going
through the questions
um please put your question in the Q a
box
so Mark asks and this was early in your
talk uh with your strip the strip
project
um why would you need any manure or end
Fertilization in an alfalfa grass field
since Alfalfa is a powerful nfixer and
also very effective in acquiring pee
from soil sources via mycorrhizal fungi
really good question
um I think we need to recognize that
manure has a lot of value and not just
nitrogen
there is a phosphorus sulfur basically
all of the 17 essential elements are in
manure
and we we tend to want to manage one
single nutrient
um
we can do that with manure it has all of
them
so there might be reasons for manure
application to Alfalfa fields to meet
the phosphorus needs for that stand and
reduce our phosphorus fertilizer Imports
there might be a need for a sulfur
addition that we don't have to do if we
apply manure to Alpha Fields now
typically firms would be applying manure
to the if they apply manure 12 off it
would be in the later years
when we could have potential for
deficiency for phosphorus for potash for
sulfur
the other thing that shows from many
studies on manure is that it's
tremendous material to build soil health
and soil resilience over time
so while the Alfalfa itself does not
need the nitrogen
it could benefit from the other
nutrients that's in them in air and it
will reduce its nitrogen fixation to a
certain level
um when manure is applied cannot totally
eliminate it but it will reduce it to a
certain amount
I hope that answers it
the next question at 100 pounds of n per
acre positive balance is this not
already a high risk of leaching nitrous
oxide losses and unnecessary expense
isn't the goal to get end balance close
to zero while maintaining good
production
really good question
the uh that's that's a question that
comes up more often
so a zero balance means that everything
we import gets exported
then we have a hundred percent
efficiency
there is no biological system that is
that efficient it simply cannot be done
there are unavoidable losses in
everything we do
agriculture included
Our Lives included
so we have to make sure that our balance
is not negative that it's not zero that
is somewhat positive but not excessively
positive
um we are working towards trying to
figure out what are the feasible
balances what can we do uh what losses
can we avoid
how can we capture
um
nitrogen losses from the barn from the
storage from from the field
so we're certainly looking at ways of
trying to capture that better enhance
efficiency fertilizers were brought up
earlier that is one potential way of
doing that
uh making those those loss components a
little smaller
um so yeah now we absolutely cannot
operate in agriculture with a zero
balance that is impossible
that would mean that we export as much
as we import
and with biological systems that is not
feasible
we can work towards better balances
though over time and that's that's why
we worked with the feasible limits now
we're not working with firms that are
over the 105 see if we can bring that
down
okay thank you so Emeline asks how can
we connect the whole Farm mass balance
concept to newer metrics measurements on
a farm like building carbon and reducing
nitrous oxide emissions
excellent question Emma thanks the uh
project that we have a project ongoing
right now on the area sustainability key
performance indicators
and in that project we evaluate a number
of tools that do whole Farm carbon
footprinting greenhouse gas emissions
type tools
and what we're currently working on is
trying to connect the end balance
from the whole Farmhouse balance
with the estimations of greenhouse gas
emissions from those tools
the concept behind it is that every time
that we exceed
the crop needs we open up the door for
losses
and that's why it was so important to be
able to document the reductions the 66
million pounds of nitrogen
uh in Imports nitrogen no longer being
used
so
um we are working on a project to try to
connect those the the mass balance
Footprints the concept is if your
balance is over the feasible limits
there will be losses including
greenhouse gas losses that we want to
see if we can address
connecting carbon footprints
greenhouse gas inventories with Max
balances
whether we are successful in that we
don't know yet we're working with the
Farms to get the data collected so that
we can evaluate that
right
um
and our water quality initiatives right
began in 1999 so we've had a lot of time
to work on it so we have to give
ourselves a little room
to work through this scientifically okay
Jeff asks comparison of nitrous oxide
loss from daily spread versus injection
of manure and he says in Spring
so our our field trials and we we had a
long-term uh study several years ago
where we looked at greenhouse gas
emissions from corner fields
uh
surface applied versus Incorporated
um the first is fertilizer and the main
observation there was that the biggest
driver for emissions was when nitrogen
was applied in excess of crop needs
so the importance of the rate trying to
get the rate correct
when you inject one error
you capture more nitrogen
you will have to reduce the rate for the
same credits
from that application
if you don't do that
you apply the same rate on the surface
versus an ejection
you will have increased the amount of
nitrogen you capture
if that then exceeds the crop uptake we
have created a problem
if you adjust the rates to meet the
nitrogen needs of the crop that follows
that injection is a really good way to
move forward because it has all sorts of
benefits not just nitrogen phosphorus
also in terms of reducing losses to the
environment
we have we are a partner in the current
project that is headed up by Dairy
Management Inc in the soil Health
Institute Nationwide
um
that project has field trials so we are
measuring greenhouse gas emissions now
with comparisons of different manure
sources injection surface application to
get better answers because this is
actually an area that needs a lot more
research
but to me a key driver is again the rate
so if you can address the rate
to meet the crop needs and not exceed
them or undershoot them
we have a good chance of reducing
emissions
the other the other thing sorry the
other thing in terms of
uh greenhouse gas emissions is
increasing homegrown forages growing
your own crops
reducing the need for imports from
elsewhere
so New York is in a pretty decent shape
for that
with our homegrown percentage
so Jeff asks a follow-up is there a plan
to measure soil biology their
mineralization of nutrients and
evaluating if changes in the biology
will play a role in more Environmental
environmental production of crops
yeah so soil Health includes
microbiology includes biology in general
right so there's there's lots of things
going on in our own team
we are very fortunate to have been able
to get an assistantship for a new PhD
student in our program and she has a
microbiology background
and will be joining us in a fall
semester to work on soil health related
aspects of nitrogen management
so microbiology absolutely important we
will be measuring that in our own
program and there's lots of lots of
research going on and trying to better
allocate a better fine or develop tools
for for actually assessing microbial
Dynamics because it is so much tied into
that sore nitrogen Supply number
that is hard to predict and that we need
to learn more about so when does the
soil supply enough nitrogen so we can
back off on our fertilizer applications
okay so Mark is having a follow-up
question on um the zero balance so thank
you I agree that zero balance is risky
and unfeasible for long-term
sustainability however what is the
potential for crop breeding for end
cycling efficiency the best soil Health
management practices reduce leakiness
and hence reduce the needed positive end
balance to say
um it says 509 or 30 pounds uh per acre
saving more money animating less n2o I
suspect that means 50 or 30 pounds
instead of 509
um
yeah so so plant breeding
um if you look at the the crop yields in
the over time
in
many states New York included you'll see
an upward trends
is a combination of better management
but also also a great contribution of
plant breeding
generating higher yielding crops with
potentially reduced need for nitrogen uh
and better balancing of nitrogen Supply
and uptake
so anything we do on the field side
plant breeding to create the potential
for greater Crop Production as well as
management to reduce
disease weed pressure whatever we need
to do keep the ground covered to keep
the carbon all of that good management
is as important as it ever was
okay Karen I've got some quick fire
questions for me for you from a more
policy ended perspective on this all
right how many farms are currently
engaged in this whole Farm
um
it's a bit in a flux I think we did
around
80 or 90 Farms last year it's probably
gonna double this year there's a great
uptake right now okay and so what is
limiting the engagement of including
more Farms
um
I I think it's the it's the basic record
keeping part
okay so it requires a little bit
different record keeping
so then my next question was how much
time should a farm set aside for
sampling uh measuring and meeting with
you and and your and your cohort in
order to go through this whole process
if someone were to do it on a year like
how much time would they need to set
aside in order to manage for say
nitrogen in the way that you're helping
Farms do that all right so for demise
balance it's a simple four page input
sheet if you have the records takes you
less than two hours to complete it and
send it in if you don't have the records
you'll be up for a lot of searching of
receipts and other stuff
so fill it out send it in our team Works
through the input sheets we often have
some feedback questions in terms of
clarifications and then we send a report
back
Farms that are really interested we are
available to meet with them so we could
have follow-up calls or follow-up visits
if that's desired they don't have to
in terms of the field-based materials
the depth of management policy requires
yield measuring and that is a bit of a
stumbling block for some if you have
yield monitors you'll get a yield data
on the go if you drive trucks over
skills you will have field base level
information which is all helping with
with that process
so that's probably a slower adoption the
field balances that we're developing Now
does not require going back to the field
so that will that will take a barrier
away
in terms of we don't have to go back and
take C's and T's
uh it's not part of the policy right now
we're exploring what that could be with
our committees
um so I don't know at the minimum I
would say one day a year
uh if they want to be more involved we
can make it a lot more than that
so of your 80 firms that you have
currently engaged how many of them are
actively experimenting versus how many
of them are sort of following your
recommendations
and I don't know I there's there's a lot
of experimenting going on naturally on
farms I think management changes
I don't have a good sense of how many
would be doing on Farm experiments or
other ways of evaluating keep in mind
with the numbers I'm telling you right
now those are the ones we get to see so
there will be plenty of opportunity for
Farms to
pick up some of these tools and us not
being involved in it
Peter do you want to ask your question
yes Karine thanks for a great
presentation I was just wondering if you
can say a little bit about how you
address uh both at the farm scale and
the field scale how you address crop
nitrogen fixation and soil
mineralization soil and supply
so right now most of the the the big
supplies of nitrogen are for corn for
crops that actually need the nitrogen so
and fixation is is not part of that
right now
in terms of the mass balance we are
including and fixation as a category
but it is listed separately
on the mass balance
and that is done because we only want to
include uh
things we can measure with some level of
certainty
so the end fixation component of a farm
has Alfalfa or soybeans in their
rotation is listed separately as sort of
a range it's between zero and the max
that the plant can fix
just because that number is so uncertain
so that's usually a discussion point if
a farm comes back with a negative
balance but they have a fall for them we
say okay take a we take a look at the
alpha and fixation and you're doing okay
um
animalization soil and supply
in the mass balance approach
we are looking at Imports versus exports
and everything in the middle is is
subject to management accumulation and
loss
um
at the whole Farm level that is that is
the only thing we need at this stage
because that identifies when there is an
opportunity and that gets us thinking
and discussing and exploring what the
options might be for making changes
in terms of the field balances we are
now working with Farms to develop yield
stability zones
that identify where the soil and supply
is potentially higher
uh compared to other parts of that field
or other fields
so that's a a item that is adjustable as
we move forward the soil and supply and
we're learning more about that now
through our yield mapping
yield stability zones with the Farms
it is absolutely given that the highest
healing fields are the highest yielding
areas need the least amount of nitrogen
per unit of output
and our recommendation system recognizes
that
okay that's great thank you just a
another quick thing on the inputs do you
consider
atmospheric deposition uh that would be
you know relatively modest uh in most
locations but as we I think as we
tighten up the management of nitrogen
it's I wonder if you think about that
and then in some you know livestock
areas there could be local emission and
deposition of ammonia that might be more
important part of the end balance
but the whole Pharma mass balance level
the and the position is listed as a
estimate also
together with n fixation other nitrogen
sources
um
in this whole Farmhouse balance tool our
Focus was really on what can we manage
directly at the farm level
so that's the reason why it's listed as
recognizing that there is some nitrogen
that comes from the air
um but we focus on the things we can
actually change at the farm level
directly
like feed Imports like fertilizer
decisions
I want to thank you both for your great
presentations today
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu